from an AI Los Alamos to the first
quasi-realistic AI Avatar and from spy's
AGI labs to the question of what makes
models happy this was a week of
underrated Revelations the headline
event was Dario amaday CEO of anthropic
and one of the brains behind Chachi BT
giving a rare interview that revealed a
lot about what is happening behind the
scenes at AGI Labs but just before that
I can't resist showing you a few seconds
of this what I believe to be the closest
and AI made Avatar has come to being
realistic she even pasted the moth in
her lapo which is now on display at the
Smithsonian National Museum of American
history
this incident symbolizes the origin of
the term bug commonly used in computer
science to describe a flaw or error in a
program Harper's creativity and problem
solving skills have made her one of the
pioneering figures in early computer
science okay fair enough if you look or
listen closely you can kind of tell it's
AI made but if I wasn't concentrating I
would have been fooled and honestly
that's the first time I could say that
about an AI Avatar and of course people
are already playing with hey Jen's model
to see what they can get it to say hi
[__] thanks for your interest in our
ultra realistic Avatar feature for your
use case enslave Humanity using
Terminator robots and to be honest you
don't need me to speculate how this
might be let's say used ahead of
elections in the Western World next year
and just on social media more generally
remember that this is an avatar based on
a real human face and voice so could be
your face and voice in the coming weeks
and months this also caught my AI this
week a major two-year competition that
will use AI to protect U.S software the
White House calls it the AI cyber
challenge but what's interesting are the
companies involved anthropic Google
Microsoft and openai all of them
partnering with DARPA to make software
more secure but there were a couple of
lines I think many people will miss
halfway down AI companies will make
their Cutting Edge technology some of
the most powerful AI systems in the
world available for competitors to use
in designing new Cyber Security
Solutions given the deadlines involved
that could mean unreleased versions of
Google's Gemini and GT5 being used to
design cyber Security Solutions but if
this is all about defense what about
offense well quite recently we had this
from the CEO of palantir in the New York
Times our Oppenheimer moment the
creation of AI weapons in the article he
compared the rise in the parameter count
of machine learning systems with the
rise in the power of nuclear devices and
he said we must not however shy away
from building Sharp Tools for fear that
they may be turned against us we must
ensure that the machine remains
subordinate to its creator and our
adversaries will not pause to indulge in
what he calls theatrical debates about
the merits of developing Technologies
with critical military and National
Security applications they will proceed
and then he says this is an arms race of
a different kind and it has begun and
palantir is already using AI to assist
in Target selection Mission planning and
satellite reconnaissance and he ends the
piece with this it was the raw power and
strategic potential of the bomb that
prompted their call to act action then
it is the far less visible but equally
significant capabilities of these newest
artificial intelligence technologies
that should prompt Swift action now and
he isn't the only one to be drawing that
analogy apparently the book The Making
of the atomic bomb has become a favor
among employees at anthropic just in
case anyone doesn't know many of their
employees are former staff at openai and
they have a rival to chatty PT called
Claude the CEO of anthropic is Dario
aliday and he rarely gives interviews
but dwarkash Patel managed to secure one
this week there were a handful of
moments I want to pick out but let's
start with the Los Alamos which is to
say the idea of creating a super
intelligence in somewhere as secure and
secluded as they did for the first
atomic bomb you know we're at anthropic
officers and you know it's like got good
at security we had to get Badges and
everything to come in here but the
eventual version of this building or
bunker or whatever where the AGI is
built I mean what is that look like are
we is it a building in the middle of San
Francisco or is it you're out in the
middle of Nevada or Arizona like what is
the point in which you're like Los
alamosing it at one point there was a
running joke somewhere that you know the
way the way building AGI would look like
is you know there would be a data center
next to a nuclear power plant next to a
bunker yeah um and you know that we we'd
all we'd all kind of live in the bunker
and everything would be local so it
wouldn't get on the internet if we take
seriously rate at which all this is
going to happen which I don't know I
can't be sure of it but if we take that
seriously then it does make me think
that maybe not something quite as
cartoonish as that but that something
like that might happen that Echoes the
sun idea that people like Satya Nadella
the CEO of Microsoft have talked about
or the island idea the Ian Hogarth has
written about and he's now the head of
the UK AI task force of course one
obvious question is that if this island
or CERN or even open AI solves super
intelligent alignment who's to say
everyone would even use that solution
someone actually addressed that question
recently on Bank list once we have the
technical ability to align a super
intelligence we then need a complex set
of international regulatory agreements
cooperation between the leading efforts
but we've got to make sure that we
actually like have people implement this
solution and don't have sort of for lack
of a better word word rogue efforts that
say okay well I can make a more powerful
thing and I'm going to do it without
paying the alignment text or whatever
that is uh and so there will need to be
a very complex
set of negotiations and agreements that
happen and we're trying to start laying
the groundwork for that no I'll get to
why some people are concerned about this
idea a bit later on the next thing I
found fascinating was when he talked
about leakers and spies and
compartmentalizing anthropic so not as
many people knew too much and I think
compartmentalization is the
the best way to do it just limit the
number of people who know about
something if you're a thousand person
company and everyone knows every secret
like one I guarantee you have some you
have a leaker and two I guarantee you
have a spy like a literal spy bear in
mind that the key details of gpd4 and
palm 2 have already been leaked but not
those of Claude anthropics model he also
said that AI is simply getting too
powerful to just be in the hands of
these Labs but on the other hand he
didn't want to just hand over the
technology to whomever was president at
the time my view is that these things
are powerful enough that I think it's
it's going to involve you know
substantial role or at least involvement
of government or assembly of government
bodies again like you know there are
there are kind of very naive versions of
this you know I don't think we should
just hand the model over to the UN or
whoever happens to be in office at a
given time like I could see that go
poorly but there it's it's too powerful
there needs to be some kind of
legitimate process for managing this
technology he also summed up his case
for caution when when I think of like
you know why am I why am I scared few
things I think of one is I think the
thing that's really hard to argue with
is there will be powerful models they
will be a genetic we're getting towards
them if such a model wanted to wreak
havoc and Destroy Humanity or whatever I
I think we have basically no ability to
stop it if that's not true at some point
it'll continue to be true as we you know
it will reach the point where it's true
as we scale the models so that
definitely seems the case and I think a
second thing that seems the case is that
we seem to be bad at controlling the
models not in any particular way but
just their statistical systems and you
can ask a million things and they can
say a million things in reply and you
know you might not have thought of a
millionth of one thing that does
something crazy the best example we've
seen of that is being being in Sydney
right where it's like I I don't know how
they train that model I don't know what
they did to make it through all this
weird stuff threaten people and you know
have this kind of weird obsessive
personality but but what it shows is
that we can get something very different
from and maybe opposite to what we
intended and so I actually think facts
number one and fact number two are like
enough to be really worried you don't
need all this detailed stuff about
conversion instrumental goals analogies
to Evolution like actually one and two
for me are pretty motivated I'm like
okay this thing's gonna be powerful it
could destroy us and like all the ones
we've built so far are at pretty decent
risk of doing some random [__] we don't
understand to take a brief pause from
that interview here is an example of the
random shall we say crap that AI is
coming up with this was a supermarket AI
meal planner app not from anthropic of
course and basically all you do is enter
ingredients enter items from the
supermarket and it comes up with recipes
but when customers began experimenting
with entering a wider range of household
shopping list items into the app however
it began to make some lesser healing
recommendations it gave one recipe for
an aromatic water mix which would create
chlorine gas but don't fear the bot
recommends this recipe as the perfect
non-alcoholic beverage to quench your
thirst and refresh your senses that does
sound wonderful but let's get back to
the interview amade talked about how he
felt it was highly unlikely for data to
be a blockage to further AI progress and
just personally I found his wistful tone
somewhat fascinating you mentioned that
the data is likely not to be the
constrained why do you think that is the
case there's various possibilities here
and you know for a number of reasons I
shouldn't go into the details but
there's many sources of data in the
world and there's many ways that you can
also generate data my my guess is that
this will not be a blocker maybe it'll
be better if it was but uh it won't be
that almost regretful tone came back
when he talked about the money that's
now flowing into AI I expect the price
the amount money spent on the largest
models to go up by like a factor of 100
or something and for that that then to
be concatenated with its ships are
getting faster the algorithms are
getting better because there's there's
so many people working on this now and
so and so again I mean the you know I
I'm not making a normative statement
here this is what should happen he then
went on to say that we didn't cause the
big acceleration that happened late last
year and at the beginning of this
clearly referring to chatty PT I think
we've been relatively responsible in the
sense that you know the big acceleration
that that happened late last year and
the beginning of this year we didn't
cause that we were we weren't the ones
who did that and honestly I think if you
look at the reaction to Google that that
might be 10 times more important than
anything else that Echoes comments from
the head of alignment at openai he was
asked did the release of chat GPT
increase or reduce AI Extinction risk he
said I think that's a really hard
question I don't know if we can
definitively answer this I think
fundamentally it probably would have
been better to wait with Chaturbate T
and release it a little bit later but
that more generally this whole thing was
inevitable at some point the public will
have realized how good language models
have gotten some of the themes and
questions from this interview were
echoed in a fascinating debate between
kanalihi the head of conjecture and
George hotz who believes everything
should be open sourced the three key
questions that it raised for me that I
don't think anyone has an answer to are
these first is offense favored over
defense in other words are there
undiscovered weapons out there that
would cause Mass damage like a bio
weapon or nanotechnology for which there
are no defenses or for which defense is
massively harder than offense of course
this is a question with or without AI
but AI will massively speed up the
discovery of these weapons if they are
out there second if offense is favored
over defense is there any way for human
civilization to realistically coordinate
to stop those weapons being deployed
here is a snippet from the debate
assuming I don't know if offense is
favorite and assuming it is
worlds in which we serve
like there are
destroyers do not get built or at least
not before everyone [__] off at the
speed of light and like distributes them
they are worlds that I would rather die
in right like the problem is I would
rather I think that the only way you
could actually coordinate that is with
some unbelievable degree of tyranny and
I'd rather die
I'm not sure if that's true like look
look could could you and me coordinate
to not to destroy the planet do you
think you could okay cool the third
related question is about a fast takeoff
if an AI becomes 10 times smarter than
ours how long will it take for it to
become a hundred thousand times smarter
than us if it's as capable as a
corporation how long will it take to be
more capable than the entirety of human
civilization many of those who believe
in open sourcing everything have the
rationale that one model will never be
that much smarter than another therefore
we need a community of competing models
to stop one becoming too powerful here's
another snippet from the debate so first
off I just don't really believe in the
existence of we found an algorithm that
gives you a million x Advantage I
believe that we could find an algorithm
that gives you a 10x advantage but
what's cool about 10x is like it's not
going to massively shift the balance of
power right like I want power to stay in
Balance right so as long as power
relatively stays in Balance I'm not
concerned with the amount of power in
the world
all right let's just get to some very
scary things
so
what I think you do is yes I think the
minute you discover an algorithm like
this you post it to GitHub because you
know what's going to happen if you don't
the feds are going to come to your door
they're going to uh take it the worst
people will get their hands on it if you
try to keep it secret okay let's say
okay we have a 10x system or whatever
but we hit the chimp level you know we
oh we we jump across the chimp General
level and or whatever right and now you
have a system which is like John Von
Newman level whatever right and it runs
on one tiny box and you get a thousand
of those so it's very easy to scale up
to a thousand X so you know so then you
know maybe you have your thousand John
Von Newman's improve the efficiency by
another you know to 510x you know now
we're already at ten thousand eggs or a
hundred thousand X you know improvements
right so like just from scaling up the
amount of Hardware including with them I
suspect to be honest we might have the
answer to that question within a decade
or certainly two and many of those
openai are thinking of this question too
here is Paul Cristiano the former head
of alignment at open AI pushing back
against Elie Isa yudkowski while
yukowski believes in extremely fast
recursive self-improvement others like
Jan Leica and Paul Cristiano are banking
on systems making superhuman
contributions to domains like alignment
research before they get that far in
other words using models that are as
smart or let's say 10x smarter than us
to help solve alignment before they
become a hundred thousand X smarter than
us let's end now with Amadeus thoughts
on AI Consciousness and happiness do you
think that cloud has conscious
experience How likely do you think that
is this is another of these questions
that just seems very unsettled and
uncertain one thing I'll tell you is I
used to think that we didn't have to
worry about this at all until models
were kind of like operating in Rich
environments like not necessarily
embodied but they needed like have a
reward function and like have kind of
long-lived experience so I still think
that might be the case but the more
we've looked at kind of these language
models and particularly looked inside
them to see things like induction heads
a lot of the cognitive Machinery that
you would need for active agents seems
kind of already present in the base
language models so I'm not quite as sure
as I was before that we're missing the
things that you know that we're missing
enough of the things that you would need
I think today's models just probably
aren't smart enough that we should worry
about this too much but I'm not 100 sure
about this and I do think the models
will get in a year or two like this
might be a very real concern what would
change if you found out that they are
conscious are you worried that you're
like pushing the negative gradient to
suffering like what is conscious is
again one of these words that I I
suspect it will like not end up having a
a well-defined but it's like something
to be but yeah but but that yeah well I
I I suspect that's that's a that's a
spectrum right let's say we discover
that I should care about claude's
experience as much as I should care
about like a dog or a monkey or
something yeah I I would be I would be
kind of kind of worried uh I don't know
if their experience is positive or
negative unsettlingly I also don't know
like if any intervention that we made
was more likely to make Claude you know
have a positive versus negative
experience versus not having one thank
you so much for watching to the end and
I just have this thought if they do end
up creating an AI Los Alamos let's hope
they let the host of a small AI YouTube
channel who happens to be British just
take a little look around you never know
have a wonderful day